let's uh I think we have time for one
more caller so we're gonna go to we're
going back to 7 1 7 who wasn't there
before 7 1 7 seems to really want to get
on so I'm hoping this time we'll be able
to hear 7 1 7 go ahead
hey can you hear me we can't who's this
okay yes this is Logan how are you good
go ahead Logan oh no Logan right when
you got to the question you can you're
now in the background it sounds like
maybe you've got a bad Bluetooth setup
however bit hello can you hear me
yes go ahead Logan with the question
before we lose you buddy yes so
candidates like Don Blankenship the
neo-nazi from California do you believe
do you believe that the media vilifying
these people is giving them free press
now thankfully as you saw on Tuesday Don
Blankenship cloth yeah
and was demolished but candidates like
roaring more almost one Donald Trump
definitely one so do you believe the
media is somehow culpable for that well
listen here's the thing that you will
all any time any extremist is given any
airtime of any kind you will get an
argument from some that say your
platform you're giving them a platform
if you didn't give him a platform they
would just go away
I think history tells us that not giving
them a platform actually allows these
ideas to use whatever word you want
Fester or ferment or build power or
whatever and that you know the the
number of people if you put a white
supremacist on TV responsibly right not
as giving them a five minutes to do a
monologue that's unchallenged but if you
put a white supremacist on TV
responsibly with a host or interviewer
who's prepared to engage them on the
merits of their ideas whatever number of
people might be turned to white
supremacy by seeing that interview will
be out done I believe by the number of
people who will be made aware of the
danger that these people exist and will
be more vigilant and ensure to the
extent that they can that those idea
don't become mainstream so I understand
the point you're making but I don't
think in the net it actually works out
that way no I think he said thank you
but I think Logan might have the worst
connection of today that does it for
calls thanks to everybody that called it
and we will take calls again